you can't please everyone and that goes
double for people who consider
themselves to be hardcore Disney fans
more than a few Disney diehards are up
in arms on Twitter over the trailer for
the upcoming live-action remake of Mulan
which will not be a musical and will
exclude a couple of key characters the
beloved 1998 animated original centered
on fom Mulan a peasant girl who
disguises herself as a man so that she
can enlist in the Chinese army in place
of her ailing father to help defend her
country against the marauding Huns at
her side on her journey is Mu Shu a tiny
wisecracking dragon who hopes to restore
his tarnished honor by helping Mulan
succeed a task made more difficult by
general li Shang who serves as an
antagonist for much of the film before
being won over by mulan's bravery and
cleverness shang and moo shu are the
characters at the center of the Twitter
uproar as it's been revealed that
neither will appear in the live-action
film a revelation that didn't sit well
with legions of passionate fans of the
original this isn't to say that many of
these fans are going to refrain from
buying a ticket disgruntled fans still
rage attending movies as a common theme
among the outpouring of angry tweets as
illustrated by a tweet from user dear
Wallflower who acknowledged that the
version of Mulan featured in the trailer
looks remarkably badass saying this is
the Mulan we obviously wanted but moo
shu li Shang music I mean
imma go see it regardless but i'ma also
be sad the sentiment was echoed by user
goody butts who ran down her complete
list of reactions to the trailer in her
tweet cries watching the Mulan trailer
listens to all make a man out of you
remembers there won't be musical numbers
or Mu Shu cries some more remains
excited for this movie one user even
flat-out stated that they were
predisposed to rage at the idea of a
non-musical version of Mulan but that
the trailer pretty much won them over
saying I want to hate the Mulan remake
but the way she twiddles her sword with
her hair flowing in the wind
it looks god-tier meanwhile user Mike
McDonald III pointed out that it's
unrealistic to expect the same movie so
yah mad that Disney live-action remakes
are just shot-for-shot with the animated
movies but y'all mad that this Mulan has
its own vision from its
animated counterpart he has a heck of a
points this maze live-action version of
Aladdin although it raked in nearly a
billion dollars in worldwide box office
receipts has been called out by fans and
critics alike for being a by-the-numbers
recreation of the original that doesn't
bother to carve out its own unique
vision the same complaints have been
leveled preemptively at the Lion King
which uses CGI to render its characters
in live-action of course
The Lion King has been blowing away
preview audiences so it may prove to be
the film that pokes king-sized holes in
those way too early criticisms
conversely Tim Burton's recent remake of
Dumbo drew fire for deviating too much
from the original story ultimately that
film was among the least successful of
the mouse houses live-action
re-imaginings of their classic library
it's almost as if the Disney faithful
simply have no idea what exactly they
want from these remakes before or after
they've been released although that
doesn't seem to stop them from
purchasing tickets with only the one
teaser trailer to go on Mulan's creative
team appears to be on the right track
actress yi Fei Liu looks awesome in the
title role and the original movie based
on an ancient Chinese legend tells a
complex story with themes relevant to
our times one that will lend itself well
to a more serious treatment without
singing dancing and talking dragons the
flick hits theaters on March 27th 2020
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]